hi there Steve coffin here this is my
studio okay so it's already study in a
way although it's quite portable Steve
Kaufman talking about languages if you
liked my video give me a like subscribe
to my channel I'm supposed to say those
things so I do I usually forget today
I'm gonna talk about speaking like a
native sounding like a native because
it's a discussion that showed up on sort
of in response to my latest video which
I did in Japanese but I just wanted to
point out that this is where I study so
I have my computer here two screens
sometimes I study on link using the
computer
mostly however I use my iPad because
it's more comfortable to sit down and I
do my linking on my iPad if I go if I go
down to the gym here I take my audio
with me on my ipod touch sorry
of course I'll use my ear pods I'm not a
paid agent for Apple it's just that I've
kind of grown used to their products and
I'm also experimenting with trying to
improve the quality of my videos so I I
had a microphone that attached to my
iPhone which I'm using to film this
earlier and there was some comment that
the sound was not that great so I'm now
experimenting with the lapel mic we'll
see how that goes
at any rate sounding like a native so I
did a video in Japanese and there was
some discussion how well does the speak
Japanese and so forth and while he
speaks it okay but you know the
pronunciation could be better it doesn't
sound like a native and so there's some
sounding like a native obviously when we
study a language the we're trying to
imitate and the model that we try to
imitate inevitably is the native speaker
we want to sound like a native speaker
it might be a native speaker from
Scotland or Australia or from Brazil or
Portugal or from Quebec or France but we
have a model which is the native speaker
and we imitate the pronunciation we omit
the use of words we might imitate some
of the gestures you know for speaking
Italian jerath or whatever I referred
CMOS a
or in from so you get into the sort of
imitating the gestures we are imitating
the culture of another language group
similarly I'm trying to improve my mouth
if I see a target words on a television
screen knife down and try to watch how
these swings because I would like to
swing like Tiger Woods however the
reality is that I have I can't think of
anyone that I know that speaks a foreign
language that is a language that they
learned you know after the age of
whatever 15 that sounds like a native
they can sound very close to a native
they might sound like a native for a
short period of time but something will
give them away and that's certainly true
like the language that I speak the best
after English is French and if I speak
French to someone especially in short
bursts then I think maybe not French but
maybe Belgian or maybe Swiss or maybe
something different or Canadian or like
something sounds a bit not quite like
ways the way we speak although it sounds
very fluent similarly you know and my
Japanese is not as good as my French so
I really even be less likely to speak
like a native and I don't aspire to
speak like a native because the native
uses his or her language to me that's
that's art you know that's there is
there's certain ways that you pause and
there's certain ways that you put words
together things that the native does
effortlessly and that the language
learner can try to imitate will never
will never totally achieve in my opinion
no matter how much they focus on like I
don't know pitch in Japanese which I
don't understand quite frankly or any of
these other things where they try to
refine their pronunciation to that enth
degree to me that's it's not that useful
of thing to do I would rather acquire
more words for example if I compare my
Japanese to my French
in French I can read literature I can
listen to audio books where they can you
know I can listen to who's that can
listen to whatever Balzac whatever you
still doesn't do and I understand that I
have all those words in Japanese I don't
my Japanese was built around my my
business discussions in Japan and if I
had the time to spend on improving my
Japanese I wouldn't focus on improving
my pronunciation to try to achieve that
elusive you know level of sounding like
a native I would work on improving my
comprehension accessing more material so
that when I speak I'm able to bring more
words and to express myself more
accurately so imitate your so many other
aspects of how the native uses the
language rather than just the accent so
I think all I'm saying is we want to
model ourselves on the native and that's
why again there's often a dispute about
native speaking teachers versus non
native speaking teachers obviously not
every golf instructor is Tiger Woods in
fact very few of none of them are we can
still have a golf instructor who's not
native you know Tiger Woods and yet
still considered Tiger Woods to be the
model or some other Pro your favorite
problem as a Canadian like I don't hunt
so similarly if we're learning a
language we can we certainly want to
avail ourselves of all of the native
content that is out there and if I'm
having a discussion on I talkie which I
use a lot with a native with a tutor I
want a native speaker
I want to engage I want to connect with
that culture if I'm speaking to an
Iranian tutor whether that person be in
Tehran or one of my Iranian tutors was
located I think in Poland or Turkish
tutor from Turkey there they embodied
that culture that's the person I want to
connect with now in a classroom it's
simply not practical to always have
native speaking teachers and there's
certainly lots that a non-native speaker
tutor teacher can provide in terms of
help and guidance and encouragement
however the model isn't
speaker however we are not going to end
up sounding like a native I don't know
even like Luka who I think is
magnificent in the way he speaks his
French Hispanic is Italian his Mandarin
is Swedish is Russian excellent
pronunciation and maybe there are people
who think he sounds like a native but in
the only language that I'm able to judge
which is English because that's the only
language for I'm a native he speaks
phenomenally well but he doesn't sound
like a native so I would suggest that
people don't make sounding like a native
at least in terms of pronunciation their
goal trying to have a pleasant
pronunciation of a pleasant accent that
reflects who you are your native
language but that you respect the
language by using words well and let
your pronunciation forward me but if
your pronunciation is so poor that
people have trouble understanding you or
if you continue you know to to rely on
what you think the say in English their
written you know for example in English
the writing system doesn't match the
pronunciation even say in Russian if the
old sound isn't accentuated it becomes
ah now these are things that you should
be able to notice however the sum total
of all your pronunciation is still not
gonna sound like a native in my opinion
so I think one should be realistic in
that regard work on improving your use
of words your comprehension your
vocabulary pay attention to
pronunciation but be real realistic that
you are not going to sound like a native
at least not to a native bye for now
[Music]